all right so I love doing these stories
on food and how we eat in America how we
source our food how we get our food how
we treat the animals how we treat the
farmers all that so sweet green in
schools is a new initiative and what
they basically did is they took sort of
the average school lunch that they're
getting in nine different countries
including the United States and they
compared them so we're gonna roll
through some images here first up is the
United States and uh those are chicken
nuggets
yeah and some frozen peas and a cookie
and mashed potatoes which actually look
pretty good and a fruit cocktail right
so that's not that doesn't look terrible
right don't like that it looks inaudible
does that look terrible there's no fiber
on that dish and that play except maybe
a little bit in the peas right so that
may root is all sugar syrup that's right
sugar so that's dessert yeah so that's a
duders to dessert yeah I was actually
saying not that total just cuz there was
something green because yeah show me
these images they're not now I guess the
Reagan administration said ketchup as a
vegetable my catch is that you all right
so we're just gonna keep rolling through
these things oh that's crazy look at
grease a nice Greek salad nice some some
orzo like baked chicken yeah
looks like Greek yogurt some already
good it's wrapped something this is
South Korea look at screens in the
vegetables little chop dog yeah well
Brazil Brazil there's less meat on the
Brazil plate than I would have thought
but it looks like there's meat uh
Finland again they got the sweet
potatoes or whatever that is they got
out like a green soup and the beets and
that looks horrible but it's healthy
whatever that is there that looks good
Italy we knew Italy was going to be good
looks like a nice fish fish they're
given the kids fish a shallot and some
grapes yeah I mean look at that Spain
look at those shrimp I'm not nice
sometimes guys watch oh gosh macho and
cold tomato soup by the way yeah uh
Ukraine even the Ukraine that looks all
right there's something going I'm going
to have that much food Reds just kick it
friends look at that piece of beef Wow
they don't get that big of a piece at a
restaurant friends that looks horrible
that possibly if it's scary do you eat
that with a gun I'd rather go to the
Ukraine and give up my meal to a Russian
soldier who's not there yeah alright so
those those are the nine that they
looked at now I know what a lot of you
in the comments you say but these aren't
what average like they're just picking
what the supposed ingredients are they
probably look
more mail lunches well I think those
were those are sort of the average
lunches right average idea that they
probably don't put them on plates that
little bit but they put them on right
they made over lunch they prolly
Instagram it filter and all that stuff
um but is it no surprise to you that the
u.s. is the worst I mean oh I wish at
all yeah yeah yeah we incredibly poorly
and uh we start eating credibly poorly
you know it's really hard now I mean I'm
trying to feed my two-year-old you know
it's funny about my kids gonna turn to
next month which means that right now
you know we say 23 months but she's one
like until your do your one and so I'm
like you know I get mad at my Josie you
pick that up she's one she yells at a
one-year-old uh so but you're never get
something right they'll haven't uh you
can at all kids to like it's hard to get
him to eat well but you got a train it
early that it's okay to eat broccoli cuz
I don't want I do not want my daughter
eating like me I don't like that you
said train it well we did a story before
about loving your dogs and yeah training
his child like a dog I'm very
appreciative that you said train it
train it why can't we get fooling right
in this country every time we do one of
these stories we're always the worst
we're always the worst because we have
no food culture in America right so
America's were a bunch of of Pilgrims
and [ __ ] that didn't know how to cook
and then after the Indians how to make
corn and so that's what it is you know
Italy they have their own culture of
food you know Japan their own culture of
food America our culture of food is
[ __ ] Cheetos and McDonald's right we
don't really have a culture of food
right and I think that's why but as a
melting pot nation shouldn't we now now
that we have so many immigrants from all
over the world what are they saying
white people are gonna be the minority
we learned over the show because the
corporate structure here and that we
learned how to make food incredibly
tasty and incredibly cheap and
incredibly accessible and it turned out
it was incredibly unhealthy yeah but
that didn't stop people from making that
food because it was to profit and
they're still making that and that and
it was driven by the desire for a profit
margin and they figured it out in the
nineteen fifties and then it expanded
and grown it and we all fall victim to
it I mean I I drove home last night from
a movie as a Hot Tub Time Machine - I'm
sorry
bragging Jesus uh and uh and I stopped
at a KFC got one of those chicken pot
pies that I saw advertised because
literally if you advertise something on
television in front of me I will you
know by your good consume and it was
delicious
oh yeah it was so good but how do you
feel after cuz for me when I go to these
I don't tell ya you did did real chicken
pot pie it somehow because there's like
you know it's bad for you cuz it's like
just the thick cream sauce but there are
you're like why did you do the carrot
yesterday I went to this place called
beer garden in Pasadena for their burger
and they put it on Hawaiian rolls
oh yeah Hawaiian rose oh they're so
sweet mhm
oh they're so good anyway I'll stop
talking yeah people are talking about
this butter burger at jack-in-the-box
haven't gotten yet I haven't got what
that butter burger it's what you think
it is it sabotage a burger cooked in
butter and then a bun that has butter on
it and it tastes fantastic yeah well if
you're gonna do butter people if I know
one thing do the grass-fed butter I like
Ari Gold
what do you think are you on the
grass-fed butter you use a coconut oil I
love coconut oil let us know in the
comments right down below and don't
forget to subscribe